[Music]
we're releasing our first single yeah
after a long time away from music we
haven't released anything under Ellen AJ
in ten years
so we're really excited and this um this
single really represents the new sound
and just a sad old artist and it's been
a long time
[Music]
[Applause]
it's very West Coast because we're
California girls but I it's funny when
we played the music to our friends a lot
of them were we're saying that it's very
nostalgic sound things so I don't know
necessarily what yeah what that means
but I was like I like nostalgia so okay
but it's definitely aimed towards pop
and there's a little bit of any of these
influence they're still definitely
sounds like a lean aging what we
represent but fingers like why the
ten-year gap we were signed at such a
young age that I really feel like the
music industry it changed so much and
once Ali and I left our label it was
kind of like one of those things we just
didn't really want to do for a little
bit I'm really glad that it took as long
as it did because I don't think we'd be
writing the material we are now if we
hadn't taken that time yeah we didn't
really mean for 10 years and much it
weren't like perfect it's been 10 years
no grant okay we're good but it's been
yeah it's been it's been a while and I
think a part of it too was being
inspired to make music again I think we
just were in like a writing funk I think
that happens to a lot of artists and
some people are better at just like
powering through it and I think for us
we just needed to sit back for a moment
is the plan after the album comes out to
go tour yeah yeah ultimately we would
love to be on the road next spring
opening up for someone we just want to
get out and tour again we just want to
play what is your favorite song to
perform it's funny I my favorite songs
were never the singles there was a song
on insomnia attic that I used to love
playing live we'd open our set with it
was called closure I'm getting close
[Music]
and that song to me I think I think cuz
it symbolized like this is the beginning
of the show kind of thing there's
something that it'll always hold like
really dear to me just because I'm
touring but there's something about that
song I love knowing we're about to
release new music and people actually
still remember what we released you know
back in the day it's kind of neat to
hear these fans get excited it's really
cool
[Music]
you